ein galaktisches fossil das system
terzan 5 entpuppt sich als sensation
forscher der universität bologna und der
universität groningen entdeckten bei der
analyse des kugelsternhaufen terzan 5
der rund 19.000 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt liegt ein so genanntes
galaktisches fossil jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
unter einem galaktischen fossil versteht
man einen stern oder einen sternenhaufen
der aus derselben gasansammlung
entstanden ist wie das zentrum der
galaxie in unserem fall also die
milchstraße aber jetzt erstmal alles auf
anfang terzan 5 wurde bereits im jahr
1968 von jacob de haan mit hilfe einer
sternwarte in frankreich entdeckt bisher
zählte der sternenhaufen zu den
außergewöhnlichsten der rund 150
kugelsternhaufen in unserer galaxie die
stern dichte und die anzahl der
millisekunde pulsare innerhalb des
terzan 5 konstrukts übertrifft die aller
anderen um ein vielfaches jetzt 48 jahre
nach der entdeckung gibt es neue
bedeutende erkenntnisse zum
vermeintlichen kugelsternhaufen wieso
jetzt vermeintlich also vermeintlich
deshalb weil terzan 5 der eigentlichen
definition nach gar kein echter
kugelsternhaufen ist ein
kugelsternhaufen ist eine große
ansammlung von vielen dicht aneinander
gereihten und so gut wie gleichaltrigen
sternen sie sich alle durch ihre
gravitation beeinflussen die sternen
terzan 5 sind aber wie die neuen
forschungsergebnisse zeigen nicht gleich
alt in terzan 5 spalten sich die sterne
in zwei altersgruppen zwischen den zwei
sternen ansammlung liegt ein
zeitintervall von mehr als sieben
milliarden jahren
das sternensystem terzan 5 besitzt
nämlich ungefähr 900 sterne die zwölf
milliarden jahre alt sind und fast 700
stück die vier milliarden jahre alt sind
und das ist das sensationelle an der
entdeckung zwei solch große sternen
ansammlung müssen aus zwei riesigen
gasvorkommen entstanden sein
bisher ging man davon aus dass sich die
sterne in einem kugelsternhaufen im zuge
einer welle herausbilden terzan 5 stellt
also wieder wie es auch schon bei der
sternen dichte der fall ist eine
ausnahme da zitat damit das möglich ist
muss der vorfahre von terzan 5 große
mengen gas für eine zweite generation an
sternen besessen haben
er muss mindestens 100 millionen mal
massereicher als die sonne gewesen seien
sagte davide massari von der universität
chroniken es gibt also eine neue art der
kugelsternhaufen eine art die sich durch
zwei verschiedene und zeitlich weit
voneinander entfernte sternen
entstehungsprozesse auszeichnet das was
die forscher hier mit dem very large
telescope in chile und dem hubble
weltraumteleskop
entdeckt haben konnte so noch nie
gefunden werden und es wird noch
spezieller die gasvorkommen aus denen
sich die zwei unterschiedlich alten
sternen gruppen gebildet haben könnte
man sogar mit der gas quelle aus der das
galaktische zentrum unserer
heimatgalaxie also der milchstraße
entstanden ist in zusammenhang bringen
manche eigenschaften von terzan 5 m in
denen die in den riesigen klumpen
entstanden entstehungs galaxien bei
hoher rotverschiebung beobachtet wurden
was nahe legt dass während der epoche
der entstehung von galaxien ähnliche
prozesse im nahen und fernen universum
stattfanden terzan 5 repräsentiert
möglicherweise eine interessante
verbindung zwischen dem nahen und dem
fernen universum
da es den entstehungsprozess des
galaxien balz miterlebt hat so francesco
ferraro von der universität bologna wie
vor weiter berichtet könnte man dieses
so genannten galaktischen fossils einen
bedeutenden teil der geschichte der
milchstraße rekonstruieren
ja wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lass mir gerne einen daumen nach oben
und ein kostenloses abo da dafür hier
klicken
und wenn er hier klickt dann geht's zu
einem weiteren spannenden video zum
thema kugelsternhaufen viel spaß dabei
und schreibt mir auch meine kommentare
was ihr von solchen entdeckungen haltet
sollen wir weiter in der frühzeit
unseres universums forschen oder ist das
unnötiges wissen schreibt es in die
kommentare und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran